the teambridge proposed submission local
plan 2020-2040.
this new local plan which started being
prepared in 2017 is now ready for the
final stage of consultation it contains
policies which say what new development
can happen and where and include site
allocations for new homes employment
premises and wind turbines
every local Authority is required to
have an up-to-date local plan this makes
sure that we have control over where
development happens and is the best way
of making sure that we protect our
environment and supports our communities
our new plan will deliver better more
environmentally sustainable development
in teambridge over the next 20 years
what's in the plan
there are policies that require all
major developments to be Net Zero carbon
as soon as the plan is adopted and all
other developments will be carbon
neutral by 2028
we're promoting low-carbon energy
production including allocations for
wind turbines that could generate 15 of
the district's energy Supply
the plan promotes better access to play
and recreational areas more tree
planting and a 10 increase in
biodiversity on our development sites
we'll be requiring higher standards of
design using a new District design code
that builds on the best of what we
already value about Seabridge plus new
ways to make places more attractive and
easier to get around
we've made provision in the plan for
more than twelve thousand new homes to
be built in Cambridge between now and
2040 with many opportunities for people
to build their own home thousands of
affordable homes for people struggling
to access open market housing and more
homes than ever which are suitable for
people with mobility issues
the plan creates more job opportunities
investment and high-speed Broadband by
identifying land for business startups
and expansions and requiring high-speed
digital networks as part of new
developments
we're also making it easier for our high
streets to adapt to what their customers
are looking for
we'll be requiring better infrastructure
to support our communities including new
shops schools health facilities and
travel links
this local plan raises the standards of
development
enables housing and employment for the
benefit of our families and future
generations and safeguards the special
characteristics and biodiversity of our
district
it aims to create quality places where
residents can enjoy healthy prosperous
and happy lives
for more information visit
www.teambridge.gov dot UK slash LP
consultation